Coluche nous provoquait pas seulement
sur scène et pour rire il avait poussé
la provocation jusqu'à nous mettre au
défi de faire vivre les restaurants du
cœur les restos du cœur de tendre la
main aux pauvres d'ici et d'Afrique
Hervé
[Musique]
Brusini un badge une chanson en une
seule image toutes les vraies audaces de
Coluche tout oser tout faire contre le
racisme contre la fin oser braver
l'administration mobiliser toutes les
énergies pour leur dire à eux aux
nouveaux comme aux anciens pauvres tiens
voilà une simple porte de toile un
chapitau c'est ton resto le resto du
cœur l'initiative Coluche a démarré à
l'hiver 85 tous les records pulvérisés
plus de 2 millions de repas servis et
toujours toujours grâce à
[Musique]
l'audace les
politiciens bon on a on a confiance ou
on a pas confiance ça dépend hein mais
en tout cas on sait quelque chose c'est
que il y a officiellement 600000
personnes qu'on pas bouffer en France
quoi tous les jours et les mecs vous
disent ça comme un chif quand on leur
demande qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire pour
pour ça ils disent je sais pas alors
nous on sait et on le fait voilà oui
voilà voilà qu'il nous faisait le coup
du touche pas à mon pote voilà qu'il
osait se souvenir de son vrai nom Michel
et
k il y en a qui sont beur parmi vous
comme on dit moi je suis fromage mais
d'origine parmesan quand même présent
dans toutes les fêtes dans toutes les
manifestations il jou avec les nations
les patries m monde confondu même joué
avec les couleurs ou disons le pouvoir
des
couleurs comment reconnaître un français
d'un immigré c'est très facile sur vos
images les Français sont habillés en
bleu l'immigré c'est celui qui a les
mains en l'air et qu'on fouille ah pour
ça les critiques n'ont pas manqué
inacceptables ces blagues racistes les
restau du cœur quelle pub rien à faire
Coluche restait là la superstar au cœur
gros gros comme
ça
voilà ça va tu fer une vise après allez
salut tout le
[Musique]
monde